what about robots
so
is it possible to engineer see because
you're really talking about
like engineering life at the chemistry
level
but do you think it's possible to
engineer
life at the like humanoid level at the
at the dog level like or is that
like at which level can we instill the
magic of life into
uh inanimate stuff no i think you could
do it at every level i just think that
we're particularly interested in
chemistry because
it's the
origin life transition
that presumably or at least that's how i
feel about it it's going to give you the
most
and interesting or deepest insights into
the physics
but
presumably everything that we do in
build is an example of life and the
question is just how much
do you want to take from things that we
have now and put them into like examples
of life and copy them into machines
i don't know uh i saw that there was
this
tweet again
uh i think you're at the mars conference
and you were hanging out with a humanoid
robot yes
that was a fun making lots of new
friends at mars 2022 did you guys call
her match ahead of time with the robot
or
did that accidentally happen
accidentally i went up and i wanted to
say hi to the voice would that be the
correct name for the color i think so we
didn't color coordinate our outfits uh
well you didn't maybe
the robot probably did much more stylish
so for people who are just listening
there's there's a picture of sarah
standing next to a humanoid robot i
guess you like them with a small head
and perfect vision actually no i just um
i did they're perfectly there's a
lighter
no i mean i think i was just deeply
interested because um what was a sorry
to interrupt was it manually controlled
was it actually uh stabilizing itself oh
no it was walking around oh nice yeah
nice it was pretty impressive i mean
actually there's some videos online of
jeff bezos walking with one of those
across the lawn
nearby there so
yeah
um
so
i wasn't invited
[Laughter]
um
yeah but um
there you go see
that's incredible isn't it yeah see you
look at the walking robot where did the
idea for walking come from was invented
by evolution right
and us as human beings able to
conceptualize and design and engineer so
the calls will change so that robot is
evidence of life
and so i think what's going to happen is
there's
the um
we want to find where the spark comes
from mechanistically how can you
literally go from sand to cells
so that's the first transition i think
you know there are a number of problems
we want to do make life in the lab
great then we want to make life in lab
we want to suddenly start to make
intelligent life
or life that can solve start to solve
abstract problems
and then we want to make life um that is
conscious
okay in that order i think it has to
happen that order you know this getting
towards this artificial general
intelligence i think that artificial
general intelligence
can't exist in a vacuum it has to have a
causal change all the way back to luca
right yeah and so the question i think i
really like the question is to say
what are we how is
how
is our pursuit of more and more life
like i know you want to you like your
robots you want to project into them you
want to interact with them you you i
think you would want if you have a robot
dog and the robot dog does everything
expected of a normal dog and you can't
tell a difference
you're not really going to ask the
question anymore if it's a real dog or
not or you it's got a personality you're
interacting with it
and so i think what would be interesting
would be to kind of
understand the computational
architecture how that evolves because
you could then you know teleport the
personality from one object to the other
and say right does it act the same
um and i think that as we go along we're
going to get better and better at
integrating
our consciousness into machines well let
me ask you that question just so
to link on it
i would i would call that a living
conscious thing potentially eyes as a
human allegedly but would you as a
person trying to define life
if you passed the touring test are you a
life form
one of the reasons i walked up to the
robot was um
because i wanted to meet the robot right
right so
i
it felt like i was
and i i i i base a lot of my interaction
with reality on emotion and feeling but
like like how do you feel about an
interaction and i always love your point
about like is it enough to have that
shared experience with a robot right so
so walking up to it does it feel like
you're interacting with a living thing
and it did to an extent but in some
degrees it feels like you're interacting
with a baby living thing so i think our
relationship with technology in
particular robots we build is really
interesting because
um basically they exist as objects in
our future in some sense like we're a
much older evolutionary lineage than
robots are but we're all part of the
same causal chain
and presumably
you know they're
kind of in in their infancy so it's
almost like you're looking at the future
of life when you're looking at them but
it hasn't really become life in in
in a full manifestation of whatever it
is that they're going to become
um
and you know the the more
uh the example the walking robot was
super interesting but they also had a
dolphin that they put in the pool at the
cocktail party at mars and it looked
just like a real dolphin swimming in the
pool
and um
and you know it's in this kind of
uncanny valley because and i was having
this conversation um
with a gentleman mutu who was super
perceptive but he was basically saying
like it made him feel really
uncomfortable um
and i think often
yeah and i think a lot of people would
have that response and i guess my point
about it is it is kind of interesting
because you're basically trying to make
a thing that you think is non-living
mimic a living thing and so so the
thought experiment i would want to run
in that case is imagine we replaced
every living thing on earth with a robot
equivalent like all the dolphins and
things and in some sense then you're
making if you think that the robots
aren't experiencing reality for example
in the way that a biologically evolved
thing would you're basically making the
philosophical zombie argument become
real
yeah and and basically building reality
into a simulation because you've made
everything
quote unquote fake in some sense you've
replaced everything with an emu a
physical simulation of it so as opposed
to being excited by the
possibility of creating
something new you're
terrified of being humans being replaced
i was just trying to run like what would
be the absolute
you know thought experiment but i don't
i don't think that scenario would
actually play out i guess what i i think
is weird for
why we feel this kind of uncanny valley
interacting with something like the
robot dolphin is we're looking at an
object we know is kind of in the future
in the sense of like if everything's
ordered in time but it's borrowing from
a structure that we have common history
with and it's basically copying
in a kind of superficial way things from
one
part of the causal chain to another
yeah
well that's that's the video
every believed it was real
they look so real
um
and obviously the technology was was
developed for movies so
but i think we're confusing our
emotional response and understanding the
causal chain of how we got there right
because a philosophical zombie argument
thinks about um
objects just appearing right that you're
facsimiled in some way whereas there is
that cause with the chain of events that
caused the uh dolphin to be built with a
human being yeah would uh philosophical
zombies still have a high assembly index
yeah
because it came it can't be
philosophical zombies can't like like
boltzmann brains just can't appear out
of nowhere well i guess my question
would be in that that scenario where you
build all the robots and replace
everything on earth with robots would
the with the biosphere be as creative
under that scenario or not yeah and so
are there
are there quantitative differences you
would notice over time and it's not
obvious either way right it's not
obvious right now because we don't
really we don't understand we haven't
built into machines how we work so
that's i think the there are one of the
big missing things that i think
that we're both looking for this right
it's a cute robot but the but the points
there is that um the biosphere won't be
as creative if you did it right now no
of course i think that's why i put in
but in the future
it we will be able to solve the problem
of
origin of life
intelligence and consciousness
because they exist in physical
substrates we just don't understand
enough about the material substrate and
the causal chain
but i'm very confident we will get to an
agi but it won't be what people think it
won't be solution won't be a we'll get
forward a lot and so gpt3 is getting
better at fooling us and gpt 153 might
really fool us but it won't have the
magic we're looking for
you